i can't believe we're here tonight at
the oscars i'd say it's definitely a
little bit scary being up here growing
up in australia i never thought that i
would stand on this stage and i never
thought that i would be here six days
ago
i did it
dreams really can come true pretty fast
too
and for so many here tonight being
nominated for an oscar is a lifetime
dream come true here are the nominees
for achievement and visual effects
dune
paul lambert tristan miles brian connor
and gared napsa
free guide swen gilberg brian grill
nikos kalycitis and dan sudek
no time to die
charlie noble joel greene jonathan
faulkner and chris corbelt
zhang chi and the legend of the ten
rings christopher townsend joe farrell
sean noel walker and dan oliver
spider-man no way home
kelly port chris wagner scott edelstein
and dan subick
and the oscar goes to
dune
[Music]
this is the first oscar win for brian
connor the second win for tristan miles
and gert nester the third win for paul
lambert
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness
thank you to the members of the academy
for this amazing award
none of this would have been possible
without the truly inspirational dunedin
nerf
thank you to my producer bryce parker
jason garber all the producers mary kale
herb joe and josh daniel upon
and all the other heads of departments
and of course the amazing casting crew
on the show
vfx is a team effort of hundreds of
people around the world
so huge congratulations to all the
artists and production from dna wylie co
and rodeo fx to my amazing wonderful
beautiful partner mags and my incredible
boys boston and jackson up there in the
rafters right now i love you all
just like to say uh a
special thank you to my wife uh kirsty
our two girls isabella and eloisa for
all their support
and of course the outstanding work from
all the artists uh dean egg
for putting us here tonight thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
you